Hello, Everybody! My name is Markiplier , and welcome to "I may die."
Now this is a platforming game
that probably, and I say "probably" because I don't know for sure but, probably is going to be rage inducing and difficlut. *pretty much mark*
[Mark's sexy dialouge voice] In a lonely floating island there was someone who lived alone..
He never met anyone.. The only interesting thing he could see was the darkness of the void
that surrounded his Island-
Why did he stare into the darkness of the void that Surrounded his Island? *Story plot, silly Mark!*
How did he have an island anyway- *No one knows, Mark* Oh, oh..
Wait I got-
Ohh, There we go.. Ah! I see.
Ok, this is a- How I know it's probably gonna be bad is because I have to use a controller for it don't
have to, I could use a keyboard, but something tells me I don't wanna! What a quaint little treehouse
Why did I need to build a treehouse
When I had plenty of island land to build upon? Because it's cuter! Hello oh time to stare into the dark void
The emptiness Inside my soul really resonates on this precipice well like, I imagine it's just complete death but.. Oh?
No!!
Nevermind i imagine it's sunshine and rainbows beneath me oooh.
Oh Jeez how exactly do bottomless pits work? No one ever knows: no one's ever returned. I just missed that money.
What's the point of- what's the point of getting money if I don't know if I'm ever gonna return to my home oh This is?
Adorable. What am I, a little bear?
That's cute oh look at me oh look at me
Stick to a wall and jump to reach the top like super meat boy, oh? *yeh sure its super meat boy mark*
Mom always said look both ways before you cross
Oh and also try to avoid the murder spikes oh trust you me I'm very familiar with murderous spikes
Given that springs are quite literally the only thing that doesn't want you for dinner down here: ENJOY!
Ah never mind enjoy the spring not the other thing weeee
AWWWW aren't you adorable?
Okay... why is it a baby sound?
Why does it sound like a baby? it's just like that game Where you where you said the floor Was lava but only way more
Painful okay
I'm so cute(yes yes you are) but i don't know if That's Good *probably
Mmm something something Just Rubs me the wrong Way about all of This wait no What they move! Oh well thats
too bad I'm good at this oh
That is Just unfair you can't put the spikes on the wall
especially The Moving spikes That's Just Unfair all right so far so good. 'Boxes! Good for climbing pushing and entertaining Cats'
Oww i'm dead did that Entertain my cat?
Apparently not, all right
Boing okay
Yahoo Indeed
Oh i don't like that, I don't like that! OW! Thank you for that. No I did It again and jump now, okay
okay, yey, yee,
ye-ohh, AHH!
yeah I'm fine okay yeah that was not enough ju-oh ok, it was enough jump. Just barely enough 'Yumpage'
The fading floor is 50% Geological Mystery
50% evil Deathtrap
All right, here we go! Ye-urrr-y-oohh, n-yooo!
Oh, we made it, amazing. Oh that's a tight squ-izz?
Ohh, made It, okay. So we Just got to get
To oh i missed a coin, aurgh my completionist nature is gonna rebel against me but frankly i don't care so many Eyes
Oh, 'So! Many! Eyes! Why?! Why couldn't you fall into the adorable cave of love-bunnies? Watch out, they shoot!
Where's The adorable cabled love Bo-oyohayayway
Hey hey hey, don't blink at me. ah ah you got targeting systems don't you you got good old targeting systems They call Those eyes but i
Call Them targeting System
Okay fine we're fine we're fine. Missed me i think oh you didn't Need to miss me i miss Myself no boy
Okay we're good we're good oh?
Collided Into It Directly douche okay
See ya see how you miss me and i don't miss me because i'm not Bad
Well, Shit! At least I know that they don't hurt me if i touch 'em! Aye Aye Aye Aye Aye Aye Aye (Cap'n)
Never in my life have I wanted to be anywhere but right there okay, nailed that. okay Good
'And then just when you thought It couldn't get any worse you discover the wonders of the angry cyclopean murder-worms...'
put that on a bumper sticker cuz that's amazing! okay.
okay alright we're fine
Because i need to boeing i don't know but They're Boeing's okay we've got That
Yeah We Turn fright and Mildly French to be Able to run away faster no
Okay well that Was stupid of me it's buche buche buche buche ah This is bad ski oh?
Nelly me in my Belly oh i should Have Jumped well i should Have Jumped there too but That's That's Besides the point?
a stein Law Hand hand
Stein Law Hand hand oh That's amazing is that a hand With The twiddly fingers okay i'M gonna assume that oh?
Man Your fingers are tender yeah you you you Shouldn't be slamming your fingers down if They're That
Not Nimble hobo inky alright so mr
Stein Law Hand hand What Why you didn't Tommy Stein Lawn Hand hand Out a Shooting Judy i i okay don't do that Again
Whatever come on come at me bro sacrifice another one of Your amazing Hands
Nice hand point how about another one how about the other one are you gonna shoot a shoe dii oh?
Okay you're gonna botch you're about. To lose a Hand Forever i don't know if you want That Link okay well That's Sad for you
Boing Boing Boing look this is bao
okay i panicked for no i
Did It twice i didn't Know you're gonna do that The Music's Real Hype about this i'm sure i'm Glad that it's
Hyping Up This Situation to its maximum potential as it should Death come at me bro come at. Me. Bro come at me bro
Hey you Missed me wink all right give me your other Hand or shoot me with your eyes
Oh yeah mistake One of Those What a war can You chose the wrong One because i got a Blood of Steel
I got like Kirby and stone form right on your stone and like brittle bone It won't
You have to do the factory They Say the only Thing Worse Than a Worm in your Apple is Half a Worm oh?
oh
I thought i was gonna Smear like in that Image That's Horrifying oh That's Horrifying?
Okay hell is going on here hello hello friends okay ah
You Didn'T tell me that you were gonna stop there i should have looked and i would have seen That You were gonna stop there?
But Then Again i don't look with my eyes Because i'm too Busy talking about. How great i am
Which i'm very grave uh yeah?
All right we're Good we're Good
Mm That's a Narrow gap you want me to squeeze in there cuz i've Got some Pretty Good squeezing abilities. Oh?
Oh i see you want me to yum oh i missed one i gotta go back
Which i've never watched all i know is the memes from It ship Deep i
Shouldn't Have gone Deep i Shouldn't, have gone There i am Dumb oh?
That is Lava disclaimer The Lava is Actually Extremely Hot especially when you Burn your balls off
Boopy Boopy
Boopy okay we're in yeah
This Is a portal Please note That Any appearance of Dangers Merely a device to enhance Your testing experience
hahaha That's a reference oh man oh are you Funny When you're not i
Don't like that at All
Precarious oh That's What i want My last Words to be?
Curious
As i fall to my Death and then die oh, Here is my Timing there we go okay this is almost my timing okay?
Sookie
All right We did That all right used to access shit your Boinky
Oh yeah you know who boinky me point key on you not on you Actually That's the opposite
Yeah okay alright Good think They give me check ball right this Was super Meatboy They Wouldn't give me any checkpoints oh?
okay good Take That
Wow that Thing Was not Very fragile if my hand can But blast a stone Hand off of a Boss Bad Boy
Maybe Maybe i Should Have Just Been but blasting These Saw Blades Maybe That Would Have worked oh?
Okay well alright Then it's a it's the Things from Mario But Now Instead of fire their Death
Their Patented Ball slicers oh
You Block The Shots What is this i got the chest it made no
No
Huh okay well that Is a portal Doom
Gotta Go it well That Is a portal of nowhere apparently uh dopey alright uh Dokey you can't shoot me if i Jump oh?
Yeah you see how i dodge that by not Actually Dodging It and Just hoping that It Wouldn't Hit me yeah That's my strategy
Oh i don't like That
That's a tight fit
Sir
Smaller size
This Was Not The Correct Way but I'm gonna Go this move Right now ah
Frick Channel Dwarfs - That Was My first Mistake
Italy Uh Delayed Italy are literally no last coin Why how about Greedy i was
completely optional also I've Completely Ignored the fact that it's baby screams
Cute Little Baby
That's Dying a Whole Lot
You Know i like to make Goofy Noises what i'm about i i'm afraid that is gonna be my last
Actual Last Words Normally When i die stupidly Which is obviously What'S gonna Happen i'm
Gonna Try to say something Profound Like life is not the live that i did and bang and i'm Dead but
This is ha see you didn't shoot Because you were scared of me i used to be a gummy Bear like you, oh?
I'm a gummy Bear but then i took an Oak an Oak What's it
This Good Newark i was Chugged about Spit cuz i realized What an irk was
Okay all right don't Arc me bro don't hurt a Heuer to me bro
Yeah That's a Good Arkin okay That's a Gherkin Irken okay
You Didn't Need to do that
See you don't need to do that How do you how do you avoid That Which canna how do You avoid That Which cannot be?
Killed
How do you kill That Which Should not be Named
Where's Put The port When i need them see okay there we Go yeah Jump over that and then Jump over that and then i
can Fit
yeah I'm Dead is What this guy Just sang That Chuck Poot well this is gonna be bad
Well also Bad oh i hate well don't like This?
This
This Is a Doozy oh?
i can
welcome
Whoa well if i Just go one for One blanca on these Bad Boys well
yeah I'm gonna go one girl welp nup - four - One Foot One foot That
Should've Belong to you with my blood plaster Put Hidden
Well Yep One for one
I'll Get him by Sheer Number well yep i sure did didn't i there was no need to actually employ any Skill in that matter
i i brewed Forced my way Right
Don't like that at All at All at All at All at All
I'm
Gonna die my Eyes Have never Been This open in my entire existence?
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yah yah!
yah yah yah
Chabad What if i stick to the wall wouldn't that be a Smart Stratagem
That Way i can oh Yeah that would That Would be smart Yeah That'd Be Really Smart if i did that but i didn't do
That Because i'm Dumb Yeah
That's The Easy Way That's the Pansy baby easy Way i'm gonna do it the hard
Markiplier Way The Way that you know you Should do It the way that brave Boys do it brave man cuz i'm a Man
But I'm a brave Man Yeah okay well if i close my eyes and look away It doesn't really Help My situation Does
indecisiveness Will Kill me i did Better the first time didn't i i could see you i
Didn'T see you is that One okay big one all right ah
You think i don't Got this i got okay well yeah fine again if i look away and i try to reach Everybody
I'm not even looking at The screen Why am i not looking at the screen Half the time
Iii
Haha but You thought You could Wart me but You could not
All right But you can oh
Nailed It I'm the bet What is bad you have no idea how Expensive It was to install Those flamethrowers well
Then Why did you do It you know you know i didn't Ask for this Just cuz you spent on me
That Was Toasty Just Cuz you Spent Money on me it doesn't Mean that i need to be responsible for Your
Don't i i didn't see you because i was. Too bothered Looking at the flames
Well if i Just Run right into the fire and hope and pray that It Doesn't. Burn me i don't think
Wow You are not Forgiving are you
Why did i go why did i go why did i go
Fine Oh i'd said it'S fine and i didn't
Need to go and then What do i do i
Freakin Go oh wow Now i'm getting Toasted Fuck you okay well toasted on both Sides
Well i
Touched You before and you didn't Kill me i i mentally noted that It Was like oh if i touch That It Doesn't Kill me
That's a That's a Good Mental note
To have oh i don't like You i could Have Gone Why didn't i go it Was completely Clear and empty i'm
Going okay i'm going I'm not going i'm going okay here we go
See this is better i Just be done did sack up and Get Out the door with more
Just enough to be Able to
Yeah no
That's Just Unfair or see That's Just Unfair you're being Unfair to me and i don't like It you
Start There and then You can You i forgot you keep going but not that time
Oh and then i Jump right into the area that it's gonna, Burn me
He's gonna Be the one you know i said oh i saying It Shall be?
It is the one Why am i not done yet oh my god be careful those guided-missile i wasn't paying Attention so you know
Be aware the guided Missile
I could Deal With The Guided from the Houses
That's not What i didn't Know that It Was gonna be like that i didn't know when you said Guided Missiles It Was Actually gonna
track me
What do you think i am Just a Genius Here
no this is impossible okay apparently not Fairly it's not impossible it Was totally possible and i Just did It yeah i
Hate you i
Have so many questions oh come on My opportunities are being Forwarded by the i
Why did i Jump Why it's like It predicts what i'm good at What stupid Maneuver i'm going to do cuz uh!
you Know What maybe That's the strategy I'M Just gonna keep Going
i made it apparently G all right Am i not done yet What is with you what is with you Get some debts Get some
The i thing you Got Red Dry Eyes Get Clear Eyes That's It That's well yeah
Goood Musel all Right
Okay well if i Jump into him i would have Been fine if i had oak?
Duty
with The Air oh god i didn't even know there Was an arrow It Was this Falling Downward
Well If i don't Jump enough it's not gonna do do nothing yeah why didn't you these if you did last time Jump
Why
arrow arrow They put That arrow Just to make sure
you Get properly Dict Over not Just a Little Bit dict over but you Get Like Royal edict over you Get the royal
Dickens Treatment Well no I'm not clear i'm clear I'M clear Eyes i
Had that band then i lost It cuz i was too i could it Closed my eyes didn't i wait i Just realized i closed
my Eyes
before i died
With Your face Nailed It alright Final nail
That's Just Unfair i've Been through easily ten of these levels Haven't i
Haven't died don't miss her meat oh well i was so worried on her missile i totally Forgot about the fact That there's Frickin?
Normal Ass spike Owes
Spike oh psycho oh well That's also
Problem Miss me oh?
Come on i'm so not cool
no i
Didn't Get the last coin i hate you how many levels were in this Goddamn Factory i've Been Through Like 13 of you i've Been
Trying to end this Goddamn
episode oh Really That's how you're gonna Spray and pray
Well don't Worry i Got me you don't Worry about me let me worry about Blanc all right
I'm a Pro i'm a Pro i'm not a pro but you know here i go That's not
Well This That's gonna bite me in the ass well not you but the eye stop oh?
oh
There we Go oh tro serous i don't know What is that What are you Doing That's not cool at All
That's the opposite of cool so
yeah
Oh i Just Got a super well god Damn It i was Very obviously
Oh i guess i Just Got
To survive you huh well it don't be easy don't you Worry about Blanc Let me worry about Lake
And By Blanc i Mean Worry about my own ass okay i guess it's Just server well hand Grenade is Really you're gonna be it's
A bullet Hell it's fine it's fine i got this you see how i got this Watch corner strapped well Dead oh?
He gets Energy Every time i die
That's Unfair Keep Pumping Out Those for Energy no not there
Ouuuu You did that on porpoise
nope oh come on
Number Got Your Number i've Got your Number aha i got your number off the Bathroom Wall
Someone Said to call me for a Good time and this is Obviously not a Good time
But I'm having a Good time making an Ass out of you uh
Yeah Try That Try that you think That's gonna Work the Answer is no, oh?
Totally Intended Removed That Was not Intended
You Know near Mess with me you're not there to mess with me uh thought You were going to corrupt me oh?
you Thought The Pieces Match all right
Thank you oh that Was the free version all that Was Really Cool that Was Tough?
i got Admit that Was tough Yeah there's the fridge oh There's more Chapters so Anyway that Is i
May die and The Answer is yes i Will die because
Frickin five Thank you Everybody so much for watching Let me know what you thought of This down in the comments Below i will provide
A link to this game If you want to play for
Yourself Try to beat My score in the Number of Deaths That i had and thank you everybody for Watching also
We are going on tour in Exactly Two Weeks the first show that We Got going on in louisville Kentucky Will be Here Very Soon
So if you haven't gotten a Ticket yet
Check Out the link in the description Below Markiplier calm or Check out the little widget down there that Shows You where your Nearest
Is a Lot of Them are starting to sell Out so get Tickets while you can thank you everybody so much
I will see you
BA- BYE!!
DODO DODO DODO